hello and welcome to this video playing
surfer rosa fan of the Pixies okay let's
see aurico ball interesting so what
about this it win gives me my all-time
high so I better win this game okay the
Yates variation dashing out some theory
here but around here I don't know how it
continues and I should know a little bit
should know this a little bit longer
this line but it never never been much
of the focus of current current theory
and therefore I never looked at it much
so c4 move probably not I think I'll i
go back
25mm a for interesting if I go see
fourth kind of intriguing takes takes
bishop c3 not sure about it okay sorry
been a long day in my voices not in top
shape yeah a 5s is an idea pushing the
night back to a eight but I thought it
would come back into the game quite to
acclaim and then a five is the liability
so i'm not sure that he should take it
I'm thinking of d5 here maybe oh come to
eat oh okay now I'll place you fall or
rico boy is that I know can cannot tell
where he's from
yeah bishops III looks normal I was
thinking d5 but now that I think of it
hmm not sure 95 is also possibility but
I think you can take take Bishop see two
nights you form doesn't look right okay
so he wants to get this blockade running
understand on dang hmm d5 there is a
five unfortunately
still I think I have to do it otherwise
it doesn't make any sense what I'm doing
I just hope that I get it back get this
d5 back 97 now it's not good yeah but I
hope it's all kind of kind of playable
at least
95 is an option here but okay maybe I
can take c3 end and take one d5 rookie
50 Wow then I didn't have one the right
at all it isn't so bad maybe my date two
nite seat xt5 seems okay I can actually
take a five if you place not a twosome
okay context afore probably just not see
text e5 if you try snotty to this one
okay Bishop's III
ok
hmm ships III looks interesting but I'm
not quite sure about it I'd rather okay
i'm playing conservative route him
shouldn't wow wow what is he doing here
night I don't see don't see it direct I
don't see how he kills me so I'm pushing
the sea porn
I mean his rooks are really out there so
if he's not mating me with some attack
which is very possible i will win with
the sea porn
yeah this kind of thing in that was the
issue so YT group g6
I can start with night before maybe
98-92 and that's probably just good move
the Queen where does he move the Queen
actually Queenie for I go see 298 see
one check and then I have a extra piece
at the end that's at least what I'm
seeing him tonight while here here I
wanted to take I didn't see that Queenie
6 as a check but it's probably not that
big a deal now here I've got 25 I think
that should should defend check like
resolve this that's the high score 25 22
so all time high very nice very nice
very lucky in the in the last couple of
games but yeah so where is it 25 22
april nineteen twenty sixteen very nice
to 5 22 ok so that was a tough game and
probably a critical position this line
is always leading to leading to some
kind of tense positions with all pieces
on the board yeah the c-4 move awesome
yeah it's sharp it's sharp leads to
interesting play so take sticks
and yeah the engine doesn't like it it
wants to play like this maybe this is
really better I mean you can hug you
that here I still have this idea and
this looks a little bit more solid it's
very comparable to the game but a little
bit more well found it probably it wants
to play this this was also what I
expected and I wasn't quite sure what to
do as this is quite an annoying idea I
didn't have a clear concept here I was
originally intending this but you know
hmm I mean interesting it's not clear
that i'm totally worse but it wasn't
what i was was after ok this was a
complicated idea but interesting yeah
this is this and now i have six spoon
you have it bad is that the engine wants
to play look a for the interesting move
don't quite get it if i check here and
d6 Wow
my computer chess but it's strong I
cannot take it if i take him and he has
this idea in case of a capture and i'm
not quite quite getting my things
coordinated and very interesting and now
i'm ok will be 50 key five was the
problem now my position and is good g6
group g3 and after c 3 black as winning
up in that is six ok the engine wants me
to take i mean i saw that but I wasn't I
wasn't totally sure if this is what's
happening here I felt that this should
be quite convincing okay it winds its
minus three that's good I can still take
and after this I wanted to go see two
takes check and then take it and ok I'm
winning that's good I didn't
miscalculate him I'm a piece up and this
I think should be pretty clear ok so I'm
winning 2nd Luke him yeah after the
fighting game I was probably was at some
point but yeah that happens i think it
was decently played ok thanks for
watching